caregiving for elderly Americans can be
a huge expense in time and money for
their loved ones a new report shows 20%
of all caregivers say they spend more
than 40 hours a week providing that help
for many that's about the equivalent of
a full-time job close to 8 and 10 pay
for the costs out of their own pockets
in 2016 dr. Jon LaPook
asked caregiver Mike Daly about the
expense of supporting his wife who
battles Alzheimer's if you did want to
retire could you swing it financial no I
would have to I have to dedicate my
whole life to taking care of Carol
because I can afford a home here what
would you say the toll has been on you
I'm dying I really took a you my blood
pressure is like 200 over 100 I can't go
to a hospital
watches Carol CBS business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here good morning I so
remember that story in Mike Daly ended
up putting his wife in a nursing home
why are so many burdening the costs of
this caregiving you know when you think
about it we are living longer but
there's also something different
happening and families were
geographically dispersed and that means
that maybe two generations ago our
family members would move in with us we
all pitch in and health now the burden
is falling disproportionately usually to
the person closest to your to your loved
one and oftentimes the about two-thirds
of the time that ends up being the woman
whether it's her family or not look
there's a problem here on one end of the
spectrum if you have a lot of money you
can pay for care at the other end of the
spectrum you may qualify for Medicaid
that's for the people who are poor
enough to qualify on income and assets
but those in the middle boy they are
crunched and it is burdensome through
employers offer assistance for
caregivers this is starting to actually
become more prevalent so larger
employers they have certain benefit
options maybe it's a discounted price on
Senior Helpers it could be groups that
are helping you some have paid leave but
more and more I think this is going to
have to be part of our employee benefits
because it is impacting millions of
Americans do you think long-term care
insurance is it is something that most
people should consider well I think it's
very difficult because number one it's
incredibly
expensive for people who purchased
long-term care insurance there is a huge
risk because premiums have been rising
these long-term insurance companies miss
priced these policies they go petition
states those premiums can go up by 30 40
50 percent and frankly this is an
exorbitant cost for many American
families so that is why we are seeing
the prevalence of these informal
caregivers and so important to talk to
your family members while there well I
cannot encourage that enough
the subs of them and say what well I
think you need to find out from your
parents number one what kind of care do
you think you would want how do how are
we gonna manage this as a family you
know it doesn't fall equally among
siblings some siblings may be actually
financially able to help some may be
able to physically help and maybe you
need to have as a family a broader
conversation it's really hard I
understand that my father died five
years ago and I have one sister and we
were on the same page the whole way when
you have lots of family members and they
don't all get along it's very difficult
but having the conversation is your
first step finding out how much money
your parents have make sure that they
are not praying that that predators are
not preying on them and be very aware
that this is something that is likely to
impact get this seventy percent of
Americans who are 65 will need some form
of long term care very message thank you
yes time to start thinking about that
thank you very much